we're now standing inside the gate
Center for computer science and the
Hellman Center for future generation
technologies two of the newest buildings
on campus the gates and Hillman Center
celebrated their opening in September
2009 with a keynote address by Bill
Gates co-chair and trustee of the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation and
chairman of Microsoft these two new
buildings were made possible while lead
gifts from the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and the Henry L Hellman
foundation the Gates and Hellman centers
plus Newell Simon Hall and weand Hall
are an integrated connected home for the
school of computer science these two
Gold LEED certified buildings also
connect Carnegie Mellon's Pittsburgh
campus this extension of the east-west
walkway includes the Randy Pausch
Memorial Bridge a bridge that links the
gate center with the pronounce Center
for the Arts
named for beloved professor and alumnus
Randy Pausch
this bridge both physically and
symbolically underscores of the
University's commitment to combining the
Arts with technology another
architectural feature is the spiral
walkway the helix which winds through
three floors of the gate Center and
connects all of the classrooms with the
dean's office
the are bar cafe and an undergraduate
conference room in addition to the 250
seat rachet auditorium and 310 offices
all with windows the gates and Hillman
centers are home to five green roofs and
research departments such as the Ray and
Stephanie Lane Center for computational
biology